CASE YOU'RE NOT UP FOR IT COULD
GET WANT TO SEE IT, SEND A.
I'M MORE INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT TOO.
SMEARS FROM THE THOUGHT POLICE
IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
JUST AS WE EXPECTED, WITHIN
MINUTES OF THE HORRIFIC AND
TERRIFYING ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI
, DEMOCRATS SOUGHT A
POLITICAL OPPORTUNITY.
THIS COULDN'T BE SEEN AS SIMPLY
A REPREHENSIBLE ASSAULT BY A
FRINGE LUNATIC ON AN ELDERLY MAN
, IT HAD TO BE PORTRAYED IS A
REFERENDUM ON THE ENTIRE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THEN AS A
JUSTIFICATION TO.
>> THE REALITY IS THIS WAS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS RADICALIZED.
HE WAS RADICALIZED TO, AN ACT O
POLITICAL VIOLENCE, AND WE HAVE
TO ASK WHY HE WAS HE RADICALIZED
, WHY ARE WE IN AN
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY FEEDING THES
THEORIES.
WHY ARE THEY FESTERING ON SOCIA
MEDIA AND WE ALL NEED TO TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES, AN
CERTAINLY ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
PEOPLE AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WHO HAVE BEEN FUELING SOME OF
THESE CONSPIRACIES.
>> THESE TYPES OF BASELESS
DEFAMATORY STATEMENTS WE'RE
ECHOED ALL WEEKEND LONG.
NOTICE THAT WOULD BE SPEECH
POLICE, THEY NEVER NAME NAMES,
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
WHICH REPUBLICAN OFFICIAL OR
CANDIDATE HAS EVER CONDONED OR
IN ANY WAY ENCOURAGED ANY TYPE
OF VIOLENT ASSAULT?
I DON'T RECALL LIBERALS PUSHING
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY WENT TO
BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTER SHOT U
A CONGRESSIONAL BASEBALL GAME.
AND IF HEATED ANGRY RHETORIC IS
ACTIONABLE, WHERE WHERE THE
DEMOCRATS DEMOCRATS AFTER THESE
COMMENTS?
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU, I WANT T
TELL YOU, CAVANAUGH, YOU HAVE
RELEASED THE WHIRLWIND, AND YOU
WILL PAY THE PRICE.
YOU WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU IF
YOU GO FORWARD WITH THESE AWFUL
DECISIONS.
>> AND YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE
FOR IT THIS SUMMER MAN WAS
ARRESTED NEAR CAVANAUGH'S HOUSE
WITH A PLAN TO ASSASSINATE HIM.
UART MAGAZINE CALLED REPUBLICAN
CRITICISM OF THAT, OF WHAT
SCHUMER SAID A SMEAR AND
DEFENDED TUMOR SCHUMER SPEECH A
CLEARLY NONVIOLENT.
DEMOCRATS WORKED VIEW OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS THAT IT
PROTECTS THEIR SPEECH NO MATTER
WHAT, SO THEY CAN LIE AND THEY
CAN SAY DONALD TRUMP COLLUDED
WITH RUSSIA OR THEY CAN CALL HI
A FASCIST OR A WHITE NATIONALIST
, ALL WITH IMPUNITY,
BUT REPUBLICANS CALLING OUT
SCHUMER, BIDEN OR PELOSI FOR
CORRUPTION?
THAT'S DANGEROUS AND THERE NEED
TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
HEAVEN FOR FORBID IF REPUBLICAN
ACTUALLY WIN THEN THE WORLD, IT
IS COMING TO AN END.
>> THE ONLY WAY THIS WILL STOP
IS IF A SENSIBLE REPUBLICANS GE
CONTROL OF THEIR PARTY BACK AND
I DON'T PREDICT THAT, BUT THAT
IS THE ONLY WAY THIS WILL CHANGE
.
IT IS GOING TO GET WORSE BRICKE
THERE IS NO REASON TO THINK THI
WILL OR OF THIS WILL DIMINISH
WITHOUT A MUCH CLEARER STATEMEN
THAN THAT LEADER FROM THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
ALL WE'RE GETTING IS A WINK AND
A NOD.
>> THIS IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
WE ARE CLOSE TO AN ELECTION NOW
GREAT NOW YOU HAVE ADS UP WITH
PEOPLE SHOOTING GUNS.
IT'S JUST RAMPANT.
ARE THESE FOLKS NOT AWARE OF HO
ROUGH THE RHETORIC HAS BEEN
THROUGHOUT OUR ALMOST TO HUNDRE
50 YEAR HISTORY?
THEY SAY ANDREW JACKSON WAS A
KING WHO WAS GOING TO DESTROY
AMERICA.
THEY SAID REAGAN WAS A WARMONGE
HELL-BENT ON USING NUKES AFRAID
THEY CLAIMED FDR WAS DESTROYING
THE GOVERNMENT IN PLAN TO RULE
AS A DICTATOR.
LINCOLN WAS ATTACKED EVEN BY HI
OWN SIDE.
DON'T FORGET, JOHN ADAMS PASSED
THE SEDITION ACT SO HE COULD
PUNISH HIS CRITICS IN THEN THE
FEDERALIST PARTY WAS EVENTUALLY
DESTROYED.
MY QUESTION IS DO THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO DO THAT.
NEVER TRUMPER'S AREN'T
INTERESTED IN HISTORY BECAUSE
THEM IT'S ALL ABOUT FEELINGS AN
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY CAN READ
REPUBLICANS MINDS ABOUT PAUL
PELOSI.
EVERYTHING IS YES THIS IS AWFUL
BUT, NO, VIOLENCE IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE, BUT, DEMOCRATS TO I
TO APPEAR ITS PROGRESSIVES DO
THE SAME THING.
THEY WILL CITE SCALISE, THEY
WILL INCITE OTHERS, BUT THAT IS
NOT LEADERSHIP, AMERICA, WHICH
YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO DO
WITH IT WHEN THEY GET IT?
WHAT YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
DO?
TICKET THEY ARE ONLY GOING TO
GET WORSE, MICHAEL.
>> IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHAT
THEY'RE CLOSING ARGUMENT WAS FO
THE MIDTERMS, YOU JUST HEARD IT.
IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
WORSE THAN WHAT?
BIDEN'S LEADERSHIP?
WHERE REAL MEDIAN INCOMES HAVE
BEEN DECLINING SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR, OR WHERE
WE ARE APPROACHING WINTER WITH
POTENTIAL FOR CRIPPLING
SHORTAGES FOR DC FUEL AND
HEATING OIL?
OR MAYBE WORSE THAN THE RAMPANT
CRIME PLAGUING CITIES FROM
OREGON TO PENNSYLVANIA, OF
COURSE THOSE AREN'T PROBLEMS
GREAT AMERICANS ARE SMARTER THA
THIS, AREN'T THEY?
FOR ALL OF THE MOST LEFTIST,
THERE.
AND BUTTER ECONOMIC ISSUES FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE ONES
THAT ARE FRONT IN MIND, THAT AR
THE ONES THAT AFFECT US EVERY
DAY.
MOST OF US ARE SICK OF PAYING
THROUGH THE NOSE WITH JUST A FE
YEARS AGO LIFE WAS AFFORDABLE
AND REAL INCOMES WE'RE RISING.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST ABCS,
WASHINGTON NEWS POST FULL.
THE ECONOMY WAS THE TOP ISSUE
WITH 84 PERCENT SAYING IT WAS
HIGHLY IMPORTANT.
THIS IS CLOSELY FOLLOWED BY
EDUCATION IN SCHOOLS WITH 77
PERCENT CALLING THOSE HIGHLY
IMPORTANT THAN INFLATION AND
CRIME WAS 69 PERCENT.
HIGH PAID KEY PINK CAMPAIGN
STRATEGIST CONVINCE DEMOCRATS
WITH THE COUNTRY ON THE BRINK O
RECESSION, FLOODING THE AIRWAVE
WITH ADS ABOUT ABORTION IN
JANUARY 6, THAT WAS KEY TO
VICTORY.
NO WONDER THE DEMOCRATS GOT
FLAYED BY THE SAUDI'S, THEY ARE
THAT STUPID.
TRENDLINES IN WISCONSIN, ARIZONA
, GEORGIA, EVEN
WASHINGTON STATE AND NEW MEXICO
SHOW KEY RACES THE DEMOCRATS
THAT THEY HAD IN THE BACK TWO
MONTHS AGO ARE EITHER DEADLOCKE
OR CONSERVATIVES HAVE THE
MOMENTUM NOW.
THE DEMOCRATS DEFLECT AND
DISTRACT STRATEGY WAS SUCH A
LOSER, THAT THEY ARE NOW HAVING
TO DROP CASH IN NEW YORK TO TRY
TO SAVE KATHY HOUCK WILL.
OF COURSE, THEY CAN'T ADMIT THE
REAL REASON THAT THEIR
SCRAMBLING, RIGHTFAX IS THEIR
OWN STUPID DECISION TO HAND THE
KEYS TO THE PARTY TO THE FAR
LEFT WHICH IS WHY IT'S EIGHT
DAYS AWAY FROM ELECTION NIGHTS
IN THE BEST DEMOCRATS CAN DO IS
QUOTE LIZ CHENEY AND SPUTTER
ABOUT ON CABLE SHOWS THAT TO
BECOME PARODIES OF THEMSELVES
FREIGHT A TINY SLIVER OF AMERIC
EVEN KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
I'M TELLING YOU WHAT, THEY KNOW
THAT THEY ARE PAYING EVERY WEEK
A LOT MORE JUST TO KEEP THERE
CAR ON THE ROAD AND FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
THE PARTY OF FDR AND JFK HAS
LOST ITS WAY.
THEY ARE STUCK IN A DELUSIONAL
TIME WARP HATING ON TRUMP AND
MUTTERING ABOUT CHARLOTTESVILLE.
NOW THEY ARE ADDING THE PELOSI
ATTACK TO THEIR REASONS THAT YO
SHOULD KEEP THEM IN OFFICE?
HOW TWISTED AND SICK IS THAT?
IT'S BECOME THEIR STOCK AND
TRADE.
IT'S A HECK OF A LOT EASIER THA
CONFRONTING THE TRUTH, THAT
AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF GAMES AN
THEY WANT RESULTS.
ONE AND THREE WANT THE ECONOMY
FIXED, THEY WANT THAT TO BE THE
TOP PRIORITY.
AND ON BOTH THE ECONOMY AND GAS
PRICES, 36 PERCENT OF AMERICANS
TRUST REPUBLICANS MORE THAN
DEMOCRATS, THAT IS 12 AND 14
POINTS HIGHER THAN THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO TRUST
THE DEMOCRATS ON THOSE ISSUES.
DEMOCRATS AREN'T GOING TO
REBUILD TRUST BY JUST SMEARING
CONSERVATIVES AND THE AFTERMATH
OF A HORRIBLE ATTACK.
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WIN
NEXT WEEK OR IN 2024 IF THEY
SPEN